c'est un projet majeur futur parc urbain
dans l'ancienne carrière miron
pour ceux qui connaissent montréal et ce
coin c'est vraiment une transformation
spectaculaire qu'on veut y apporter
george orwell françois cormier donc
nouvel espace vert sur le site carrément
de l'ancienne carrière et le maire
coderre parle déjà de ce parc comme
étant l'équivalent du central park de
new york imaginer patrice mais faut se
le dire ce parc il y bien moins
accessible difficile d'y accéder en
transports en commun et à pied faudra
donc y apporter quelques améliorations
disons mais la mer ce matin annonce et
donc des aménagements qui devraient se
terminer si tout va bien en 2023 cela
dit certaines parties qui seront
accessibles dès le 375e anniversaire dès
2017 c'est donc un parc on va construire
sur ce qui était autrefois un dépotoir
donc à 35 millions de déchets qui sont
toujours enfoui sous ce site
et là on va y construire un ce que ce
qu'on nous promet être magnifique parc
quel nom vote il porte et on écoute la
tue l'idée du mercader j'aime beaucoup
monsieur bac je vu ce que fait qu'un
d'ailleurs même quand je suis allé au
china l'importance de frédéric back au
niveau du développement durable mongole
fin aux touches travailler ensemble mais
très certainement assez rapidement on
voyait trouver un nom est-ce qu'il sera
prêt pour le 375e
une partie seulement 25 environ 25
hectares sur les 192 états possibles 192
ha bon par ailleurs officiel monsieur
pichet nouveau chef de la police
honoraire et l'assermentation avait lieu
cet après midi à l'hôtel de ville deux
absences remarquées patrice d'abord le
syndicat qui n'étaient pas là n'a pas
voulu assister à cette cérémonie
la fraternité qui avait dit on va
continuer les moyens de pression donc le
port des pantalons malgré tout est aussi
marc parent qui n'étaient pas là
l'ancien chef de police qui donc cette
sa place aujourd'hui on ne savait pas
trop pourquoi il est absent on sait
qu'ils se marient en fin de semaine
ne sais pas c'est la raison de l'absence
l'a dit philippe pichon est devenu le
38e chef de police de la ville de
montréal devant les médias loin de lui
l'idée de se mettre les pieds dans les
plats il s'est gardé loin de la
controverse sur les priorités qu'il
voulait donner à ce service de police
on les écoute donc suivi d'un porte
parole de l'opposition dès lundi je
commence à tourner sur le terrain je
veux voir mes policiers je vais
rencontrer mon équipe de direction et
des choses qu'on va mettre en place mais
aujourd'hui je suis encore savourer de
cette journée-là d'assermentation le
taux de criminalité a atteint un creux
historique les cours la police continue
à augmenter
alors il est important d'essayer de
trouver des moyens de réduire les coûts
et patrice à chaque fois qu'on posait
une question à monsieur à monsieur piché
c'est à peu près la même réponse
laissez moi profiter de ma journée
ensuite j'ai rencontré mais j'en ai
ensuite je pourrai vous rencontrer à
nouveau pour vous faire part de mes
priorités
la demande d'entrevue et déjà envoyé
françois merci l'humain au revoir au
revoir